could a monster be lurking in our oceans
and no we're not talking about the Loch
Ness monster or the Megalodon we're
talking about a creature you've probably
never heard of is a Moses or but what's
a Moses or could the Moses or have
survived the great extinction and if it
did how would it change our oceans this
is what if and here's what would happen
if Mosasaurus were still alive in 2014 a
british tourist spotted a strange
creature while on a cruise ship in the
Gulf of Mexico it became known as the
Carnival Cruise Monster and the
description sounded a lot like a long
extinct apex predator the mosasaur but
if the mosasaur had survived the
extinction event which killed off
three-quarters of the plant and animal
species on earth and we definitely know
about it it would have completely
changed what our oceans look like and
how we use them in fact if the mosasaur
was still roaming our oceans the
Megalodon might never have existed but
how can one animal have such a huge
impact these nightmarish marine animals
were actually giant lizards kind of like
the land-dwelling Komodo dragons but
they evolved for life in the ocean their
Anatomy made them dangerous predators
imagine a lizard monster with the double
hinged jaw of a snake massive teeth and
a tail like a shark oh and they could be
as large as 18 meters long that's four
meters longer than your average yellow
school bus they basically ate anything
they wanted no fish dolphins sharks
whales or even other mosasaurs were safe
fossils from this species have been
found on every continent including
Antarctica evidence that these lizard
Kings dominated the oceans in the
Cretaceous period but they weren't all
so ferocious with some species being as
small as 1 meter long then how did they
become so terrifying their ancestors
were more like the marine iguanas living
on the Galapagos Islands today around 90
million years ago these lizards would
have ventured into the ocean for food at
first they stayed close to the shoreline
but as they evolved they started to make
the open ocean their home the evolution
of their powerful tail vertebrae made
them skilled and speedy swimmers helping
them move further away from the shore
but they also remained close to the
surface because like dolphins and whales
they needed to come up for air
it only took 27 million years for the
mosasaur of Jurassic Park to evolve
of course the mosasaur in this movie is
not very accurate even though a real
mosasaur was smaller than the one in
Jurassic Park it was still a very
dangerous creature
if this species were alive today it
would completely alter our oceans but
why would it change them and how would
it affect the way we use our oceans much
of the marine life we know today
probably wouldn't exist with the
mosasaur inhabiting our seas they just
wouldn't have stood a chance against
this mighty foe instead the fish and
mammals in our oceans would look and act
much differently than they do today they
would have adapted special traits and
methods to avoid the Mosasaurus one
ecological theory is that predators
actually drive evolution because they
force prey to adapt and quickly in fact
a 2007 study found that the diversity of
marine creatures over the past hundreds
of millions of years is directly tied to
interactions between predator and prey
so our oceans might
even more diverse if the Mosasaurus
still existed but what about us
well this giant lizard would make the
oceans a much more dangerous place for
humans we would need much larger boats
small fishing boats and sailboats could
be small at hold by this creature ocean
hobbies like sailing and fishing
wouldn't be as popular and swimming and
surfing would certainly be
life-threatening and maybe the story of
moby dick would be about a menacing
moses or instead of a whale thankfully
mosasaurs do not exist today or our
oceans would look completely different
and that's a good thing if the
Mosasaurus were able to survive
extinction what's to say other species
couldn't survive - just imagine
pterodactyls flying overhead but that's
a story for another what if
[Music]